From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
So what I'm going to do is just sort of record a little opening announcement for the camera.
So when they transcribed, then nobody's here.
And then like sort of like we did at the SNCC reunion,
we'll just sort of walk through chronologically, I think that sounds good to you.
Whatever it's good for you.
So good afternoon.
Today is Thursday, April 11, 2013.
We are in Culver City, California.
Recording for the Southern oral history program at UNC Chapel Hill,
and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
I'm the interviewer today, David Cline, with videographer John Bishop,
and today we are talking to Mr. Rick Tuttle,
and I want to thank you very much for joining us and being part of this project.
Glad to be here.
So what I'm going to do to start with, I feel very strongly that it's starting with someone's childhood.
And I really believe that the things that we go on to do later are very much important,
by where we came from often.
So with an eye toward that, as you can tell us a little bit about your upbringing and how you might see that figuring in your later work.
Well, I was born in New Haven, Connecticut,
and my father came from a paternal, a long time, New England family,
a subtle New Haven in 1638.
My grandmother Tuttle's grandfather,
rode with the Connecticut regimen,
that a minute or two after the Massachusetts 54th was mowed down of the assault on Charleston at Fort Wagner.
A minute or two later, these boys from Connecticut,
who had been posted on the sea islands off Charleston,
they were on the next assault wave,
and he took a, this is a well-known story inside the family.
That's the relevance to this.
And Grandma Tuttle's grandfather, a blessed memory, took a bullet,
and later died on the Petersburg front.
There's a recent Lincoln movie out called Lincoln,
came out this year, where he had a grown-up person's decision to make,
whether to accept the federal Confederate commissioners and make the peace.
They'd come back into the union and block the 13th Amendment to abolish slavery,
which is why they wanted to get in when they did.
Vice President Stevens was there, and the half of Jefferson,
he was a serious envoy.
And Lincoln made a grown-up decision.
I would have made the same decision.
That is, take thousands and thousands more casualties of the siege of Richmond and Petersburg.
Don't make the peace win the war at abolish slavery.
The iconic photo of that that's on all the postings around urban areas,
so the advertised movie shows Lincoln with his entourage on horseback,
riding through the casualties and the dead bodies at Petersburg,
in the figurative sense that is my grandmother's grandfather.
He died on the Petersburg front, was wounded at Fort Wagner,
and died on the Petersburg front.
Now we would hear about Monroe Gillette from time to time.
My other side of the family was Arkansas.
And my mother's family had stories to tell of their own,
of reconstruction and the Civil War, which were very different stories.
Stories of torture, stories of what happened when the union army came through,
and they were very bitter stories.
These are very vivid to a little boy.
I'm the eldest and the family on that side,
who listened to these stories from Mimmie, on the one hand,
my mother's mother, and Grandma Tuttle, my father's mother.
So I was raised in the stories,
and they couldn't even agree on what they were to call it,
the Civil War, the war between the states.
And very vivid memories.
On several occasions, when they happened to be visiting at the same time,
we were living in Arkansas, and Connecticut, Rhode Island,
and Northern New York.
And we were old school family.
One of the other was usually whether it's five or six months a year,
a respected grandmother.
But they would sometimes get there at the same time.
And the clatter of dishes is one or another in silver.
It's one of the other got up and stormed away from the table.
Vivified this history.
And that made some impact.
Later, dad, there's a story in the family where dad,
well, by the way, when Roger Lat got into the Civil War as a man in his early 30s.
And like much of the Union Army in 64 when the enlistments ran out,
he wasn't a draftee.
He'd been a 49er as a young man, and then he went up there.
One of the fascinating things about the Union Army,
in his case, he was an enlistee, not a draftee,
is they could have walked away from the war after three years.
They re-upped.
A vast number of those soldiers re-upped,
and continued the fight.
He was one of them who did so.
Dad went into that tradition.
My father in the Hitler War, the war against fascism,
the Hitler Alliance, went into the Marine Corps at age 36.
And they made fun of them until they won the Almarine Hundred-yard Ash at Parris Island.
After the war, I remember we were bomb and my mother and I,
my brother and other brother, who was pregnant with Alan.
We were down in Arkansas in 44-45 in Jonesboro,
not far from Memphis, across the river from Memphis.
And we were coming back, we took the Memphis train,
and we were coming back up to Cincinnati,
where we would switch trains, and go on into New York,
and up to New Haven, and go back home.
Family made their decision to go back to the North.
And a powerful story in my memory is that,
I'm pertinent to all this, is the train broke down north of Memphis.
A lot of the rolling stock was very old.
They hadn't been trains built since the 1920s.
The pressure and years followed by with the Second War.
And the joke was that all the people who lived on the fighting men and women who lived in Oregon,
California, New York, fought in Europe,
all the people who lived in the Carolinas of Virginia and Maine
and Connecticut, New York, fought the war in the Pacific.
So the whole nation seemed to be on the move.
The trains were jammed, the hotels were jammed,
and the train broke down just outside of the North of Memphis.
And we were all anxiously looking at it,
or my dad was a little boy, but I knew what was going on.
I was five going on, six going on, looking at their watches,
and fretting about, would we be able to make the New York train?
There was nowhere to stay in Cincinnati.
And we were this little family, and mom was pregnant with a fourth child, my sister.
And me, the man of the family at age five, almost six,
dad was with us, and mom and my two brothers.
And we pulled in, as we pulled into the train station at the Cincinnati train station,
a great old fashioned train station.
There were rows and rows of tracks.
At the far end, there were no other trains between us.
We could see the New York train, and it was, as the trains do,
I mean, ready to roll, it was, pfff, pfff, and dad came off the train,
and turned to the, as he was getting off, turns to the conductor,
it was to me it had pleasant professional conversations,
and checking out the time, and said, can you help us?
And a little family, we have to walk all the way over there,
we'll never make it, that train's out of here.
It already was about two minutes to pull out.
And the conductor said, sir, I'm sorry, I can't help,
I mean, schedule, and the companies, and all that stuff.
Dad then turned to the porter, African-American,
the sleeping car, Porters Union, a fellow brand-of's Union, as it turned.
And he turned to the porter, and said, can you help me?
Can you help us?
The porter, we weren't in the sleeping car,
the porter's were around, they saw the situation grasp it instantly.
And dad, Porter looked at my father, my father,
that was in uniform, as I remember, my father looked at him,
they looked at each other, and dad stepped closer,
and showed him something, and it was a card,
and the porter turned, looked up the line to another porter,
and he was a younger man, I remember that way, like that.
He went like that, that train stopped,
and we, in a orderly way, walked over,
and we're welcomed onto the other train, I said to my father,
what is it, dad, that you showed him, there's no money,
there's no greenback, I didn't know much about the world,
but I saw what I saw, and my father pulled out the card
and showed it to me, the card was a card of the NAACP.
My father had been an active member of the NAACP,
the National Association of the Vance of the Colored People,
in New Haven, Connecticut, had coached my father,
a great athlete, and also Marine Corps,
100-yard dash, all that, and it was also probably the finest
high school track coach in New England at the time,
they won nine out of ten Connecticut State Championships,
and ran the Great New Haven Harrier Teams,
hundreds of young men, a fair number of whom were African-American.
And so, I was a little boy around that scene,
though he was no longer a coach, he had become a principal,
but around that scene, and the school where he was principal
is predominantly African-American, the Dixwell Avenue area of New Haven.
And my father was engaged civically in various ways,
not in a particularly political man in the electoral sense,
but civically engaged.
And that story, as always stuck in my mind,
is what organization can do.
To be organized, and in this case, to be organized around the right cause,
is something made a powerful impact on me,
and more I learned later about the sleeping car portals,
I realized just exactly what a good move that was.
And any of them, I grew up in the North,
and later went to Wesleyan in Connecticut,
high school, and I went to 10 different schools before high school.
Moved around a lot. The war was on a lot of people
removing around them in the states.
And then wound up in the Platt-Sprick High School,
a terrific place, like a lot of us work my way through,
all those construction jobs, and so on.
And even with a bit of a farmer for a while,
it was a little guy delivered newspapers for three years.
And went to Wesleyan University in Middletown, Connecticut.
When I was there, when I arrived, we walked in and joined a fraternity.
The Alpha Chi-Row fraternity, and our group of chaps at the local,
we were local, one of the locals, I think 27 locals,
had a year or two earlier, discovered a clause
that was a Christian-only clause, or put it this way,
to be a member of the fraternity,
had pledged allegiance to Jesus Christ.
And also, there was a hidden clause, as I understand it,
that was, I never saw that clause,
but our people, or my paternity brother said it was a hidden clause,
about whites only.
In any event, we became involved over the fourth,
I wound up being president of the fraternity,
I had an active in the house, a group of,
really quite a remarkable group of people,
it turned out, both in college terms, alumni terms,
and also just generally, civically.
And we got involved in the battle against discrimination
in that fraternity.
I don't think it took a lot of guts for us to be involved,
even in the post-Joh McCarthy era, to be involved
in the civil rights fight in the middle of a liberal arts college
in the Connecticut River Valley.
But it got us familiar with the vocabulary and the concepts
of civil rights.
And we were, correctly, we were one of three fraternities,
widely seen out of 12, who engaged in this struggle.
Some of them didn't have to, they didn't have these clauses,
others chose not to.
And I served on the civil rights committee of the campus.
But the main arena was working on these issues,
we're trying to retain the property and the break from our national.
And we did, we gave them one year to change
when they didn't do it, we fired them.
And...
That was what you're...
Well, I arrived in 1957.
I broke a hand and playing basketball, as a matter of fact.
And the joke was, oh my god, coach, it's Tuttle shooting hand.
They put me in the games anyway, I had a ball.
It's Tuttle shooting hand, the coach said, so what?
And I had to have that, but I broke my hand a couple of times.
It's the second time I took advantage of that to think of you're off,
which I did.
And did a lot of reading, a lot of thinking that you're happened to be 1960,
which is a heck of a year to take off.
I think it made some difference in my life, because I graduated in 1962.
The battle with the fraternity national went on through those years.
Were you there at Wesleyan when the city movement began in the town of South?
Yeah, my fall of 1957, the little rock took place.
And there's another feature to my upbringing there.
I was there as a little guy.
I saw something of segregation, saw a bit of it.
That was a little guy though, I was five and six.
Went back down to visit family members in my, just before going off to college,
a year or so before, sort of, sophomore junior year, and saw something of segregation
did not like what I saw, heard a lot about it, et cetera.
But I had come to a subtle opinion that this segregation business was a bad idea,
a bad idea for the people who were being affected by it,
who were Negro, African-American, and also in some ways crippling for whites.
And then, in addition to that, I thought a bad idea in many respects,
including voting rights, public accommodations, other things.
But our battle was over here in this fraternity, and then what very pertinent
sit-ins took place.
And I was out of college up in Plattsburgh when the Woolworth's sit-ins were taking place.
And I have trouble now recalling whether I actually went down and actually was in the line,
sort of picket line around the Woolworths in Plattsburgh.
I know I wasn't that middle-town.
I don't think I actually was there.
I know I thought about it, but I was sort of disconnected from campus and disconnected from other people.
A little later, the next year came the Freedom Rights.
And something very important to me was that there was a professor at Wesleyan
who had an instructor, actually, named John Maguire, who was a professor of McGuire,
was a religion teacher.
I was not one of his students, but several of the fellows in the fraternity were.
This was a pretty bright group of students, and not easy to impress.
And they were very impressed by Professor Maguire, who had come from Alabama.
He was a Yale Divinity, and then had been recruited to teach at Wesleyan, and then he did,
and went on to the career there for a while.
He wound up out here as President of the Plair and My Graduate School, and so on and so forth.
In any event, he received this we knew contemporarily, that he had received the phone call from his friend,
Rev. William Sloane Coffin Jr, that after the Anniston bus burned, which is in most high school
and college history books, survey books, and was all over the press.
First of the freedom riots, we said we have to try from here.
It's a call of conscience.
And John, I know, the call, and John, I know you have finally exams coming up.
It's a May of, and it's a first year teacher.
And there's a rather famous moment where in the world of the campus at Wesleyan, where he,
so I remember hearing it, and then later reading about it, a book by George George Plimpton + Jean Stein,
it was on the Robert F. Kennedy funeral train, and they interviewed people who were on the train in 1968.
But any of that captures the story there too, where John Maguire wanted to see the dean of the department,
the chair of the department, Dr. David Swift, and said, Dr. Swift, I know this is unusual, and I realize,
I know what I'm doing, but I have a call of conscience.
Conscience, I have a call of conscience.
Well, John Maguire had roamed at some conferences with Dr. Martin Luther King, also.
And he's got to have a call of conscience.
And I know we've not finished the semester yet, but I'm going to join William Stone call for some other people
who knew how he even went down to New York and went to Freedom Rite, where upon David Swift stared at him for a minute,
and then he said, Dr. Swift, the department picked up the telephone and said, if it was wife, please pack my bags.
I've got some young foolish professor going out to Freedom Rites, I better come too.
So he did.
And without going too far into the details, Swift was a senior person around there, and as the saying goes,
when Swift went on the Freedom Ride. Wesley and went on the Freedom Rite, my roommate and I at the time, both on Walson I had both said to one another,
not knowing about the Maguire, the faculty to faculty, the student recruitment.
We had said when the Anniston bus thing, that we were primed enough in this struggle to say, we want to go on the rides,
but literally the bus that pulled out before we could get ourselves there, we were not operational, it didn't happen.
But I know it's a, I don't just suspect, I know that I came to a subtle conclusion that when other opportunities would come up, I'd do my best to, in fact, get into this.
One thing about the Freedom Rides-and the genius of the Freedom Rites, it's not as widely articulated when the literature comes up and, but understood at the time,
as I'll mention it now, and I don't speak as a participant in the Freedom Rides; I was not on the Freedom Rites of 1961.
It was clearly interstate travel, and going from state to state, there was no question about it, that the Commerce Laws were clearly involved and that, therefore, that forced the issue.
And whoever, over at core, Congressional Qualities thought this up, assuming they also grasped that, which I think they did, and there had been earlier efforts in the 1940s to do this out at Cleveland in such a place.
Ohio, it was Istro-Coginius, and they went down. I then came out to, went on and graduated, this was the 61, the next year, 1962, and graduated.
And then decided, kind of an whim, to come west, to come to Los Angeles for a year, sunshine, play basketball, maybe play some tennis, and enjoy the beach and chase the young ladies.
The figure I go there for a year, and then go somewhere else, come out for a year, graduate school.
And it turned out I was admitted to graduate work here in some other places, I came out, my college roommate Bruce Corrill, and it was extremely helpful.
And we had, it was Bruce and Stephen S. Trott, who's now on the night circuit Court of Appeals, senior status, former Associate Attorney General in the Reagan Administration, former Chief Deputy District Attorney in Los Angeles, former United States Attorney.
He and Bruce Corrill, along with a man named Paul Cable, who's deceased, were the ones each separate times, were the ones who forced the issue in the fraternity.
We had had a precipitating clause that we'd break from the national if it affected anyone in terms of joining.
In other words, if it was a real issue, not a theoretical issue.
And it affected Stephen S. Trott and Bruce Corrill, and they said, if that clause is there, we're not joining.
They had been educated to the issue, prepped for the issue, never anything else.
And Bruce Corrill and Stephen S. Trott are two of the most remarkable of their lives, they're both mid-m I age, to the most remarkable individuals I've met.
It was here or this business?
It was at Wesley, and these were first-year college students.
Remember, I'm a year ahead of them, because I'd come in the year before, and they're also class of 62 fraternity brothers.
Trott, this is before your time and before your parents time, both of you.
But Stephen S. Trott went on to be one of the famous The Highwaymen, Michael Row the Boat Ashore, Michael Row the Boat Ashore, all at least, Trott.
So they figure into the story a little bit later in other ways.
I came out here for graduate school, and why don't I pause on that, you?
Okay, so let's just pick up there, we've got your ad to Los Angeles, and what graduate program did you enroll in?
In history?
In history.
And I came west, and all seriousness, not only was it to chase the young ladies and play basketball on tennis, but I had done a paper, a long paper in my junior year.
I mean, been a way to call it, from college year came back, on the American Progressive Movement, one of the great historians of the Progressive Movement's professor George Mowry, who taught at UCLA.
And I arrived and found his seminar was filled.
What me being me, I marched into his office hours, and said, Professor Maurey, I came 3,000 miles to work with you.
I read every single thing you've written that's been published.
I went to Wesleyan," and he said, well, I think we can work you into the seminar.
And he was a wonderful man to me.
And he wanted to back at Chapel Hill, by the way.
He had been a student, he had been very close to Frank Graham, when Frank Graham was, before Frank Graham became governor, or a senator for a while in North Carolina.
He had been a student of, he had been a professor for a while at Chapel Hill, and I want to be at UCLA after a couple of other stops and terrific man.
So I'm, but I don't know anyone to speak of in Los Angeles.
But I began to get acquainted with folks.
But I, in my case, what precipitated my engagement and all this directly was, I had been a long-wind trot, Stephen S. Trott, and helped bring the National Student Association to Wesleyan.
It was an idea Bob Patricelli had with Bob Ranford, a student body president, you know, Wesleyan to sort of get campus politics out of the sandbox and into a fuller engagement.
And I had played some role there at a conference, a regional conference, and we made a report at Wesleyan.
I was somewhat informed on National Student Association.
I wrote a letter in support of NSA when I was at UCLA, probably a letter of that little consequence, no one knew me when it was defending NSA, with National Student Association when there had been a hostile editorial written in the campus newspaper, the Daily Browen, which, so I wrote, and I figured I better get over to the office and see, learned something about the men and women who are over in NSA on this chapter.
And I then met Steve McNichols. And Steve McNichols, who later that year in 1963, became the NSA rep, was active in NSA, and it turned out, and they thought of me as a fellow NSA, having had this background, and so on.
I met a fellow named Steve Robbins, who became National President of NSA. This was the year before the CIA involvement with NSA, had been revealed by Mike Wood, and was a friend of Steve McNichols.
But Steve had done the freedom rides, in fact, from the West Coast. Part of the idea on the freedom rides was to try to fill the jails and to come in a pincer movement, West Coast, East Coast.
And in the course of that, a couple of years earlier, not only had Steve McNichols and Bob Singleton, Helen Berry Singleton, Robert C. Farrell, and later with the City Councilman, Bob Singleton, and Los Angeles, and Steve, and then Helen, and Bob Singleton, Bob's going on to be a professor at Loyola Marymount, Helen Berry, Acta, and the Arts.
They went, the Singleton's went on the Mississippi Freedom Ride and spent the jail time, prison time, and parchment, state put it, and Steve McNichols and Robert C. Farrell, he gone to the Houston rides.
And Steve McNichols have been very badly beaten, and in that ride, and if I could come out here as a very good tennis player, and it was going to forego that in the rest of his life.
But we saw each other and became acquainted. He did a very good job of bringing interesting speakers to the campus. He brought Chuck McDew, who was one of the heads of Snick, also brought Malcolm X.
It turned out we had hosted Malcolm X at Wesleyan, and it's spent a fair amount of time with him because at our fraternity, actually we had a tradition of having people, these small colleges, you do this, some have people for dinner, and so on and so forth, and really make a full day of it sometimes a weekend.
I actually spent a fair amount of time together when I met him, and then here we are three or four months later after the summer, bam, and the fall, having seen him in the spring.
See Malcolm X again, where they recognize each other, we chat, I explain, I'm now in graduate school out here following him around, and he laughed, he was relaxed about it, and he really indicated he was relaxed about it.
And then Lenna and Michael's brought in, had very strong building, civil rights consciousness, and staying connected, a little later with civil rights, had a civil rights division of an NSA.
I then pick up an article by John Poppy, who had written for either Colliers or Look about the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee and the efforts of Sam Block and Charles McLaurin and Willie Willie Wazir Peacock to register voters in the Mississippi Delta.
And it was quite a story, harrowing experiences, the segregationists trying to get them, it's a world of people not taking the man and then finding places to stay and registering voters, and people when they did try to register to vote, being cut off the welfare roles by the county governments, we're talking Leflore County, Tallahatchie County, and so on.
Either in the county or not far from the county where I'm at Tellham being killed in the 1955, this is eight years later.
And I read it, I removed by it, and thought about it, and then a good deal.
And then all hell broke loose in Birmingham. In May of 1963, we're talking the academic year of 62-63. Fire hoses, and I'm not particularly a person, what it is of the television screen, but I was, by that time I'm with a family where I'm in effect helping take care of their kids on weekends and stuff.
And then I'm with a family where I'm in the weekends and kind of a nanny figure, but that overstates it, but wonderful family.
And I had great admiration for both Norman Gabby Reskin, and Norman Reskin was something of a war hero who flew fighter planes over Nazi Germany, and his stories of him parachuting out in the marquee, helping him get out, getting him back across the channel, and flying more planes.
And I was a former RISK, Norman Reskin, terrific guy. It wasn't just his biography, it's kind of individually what he was, he's not deceased.
And I said to him, keeping in mind this freedom rider business a couple of years earlier, I thought I had a teaching assistantship lined up, I had a resident assistantship lined up, I wasn't married.
I don't particularly important person in my life in that regard. I was eager, I wasn't particularly finding anyone willing. And furthermore, and I had no debt.
And it occurred to me if I'm ever going to be able to do something like this, now I know a lot about these things from my perspective.
I better do it. And I asked Norman about it, we sometimes have a graham crackers and milk that we got home, and I'm family talking it.
And I said, what do you think? He said, well, if I were, I have mortgage in a family and a business and everything else is ever to be in your situation, I'd do it.
And that's important to me, his views are important to me. It's still notional, but getting more of a live option, the John Poppy story.
I could cite that, practically quote that story right now. And then of course, the several days of bull Connor and the fire hoses and all the rest of it.
And I come across campus, I should add that there was a, she's not a public figure, so I just mentioned her name, the young lady. I was particularly interested in with whom I had shared my notions, my thoughts about this, this, there are gender components to these things.
I shared my thoughts about this particular article, the John Poppy piece, I had no, from time to time, I had no car from time to time, she gave me a ride home to this place I was staying and so on so forth. As terrific as a lady.
So I am in the student, the, the Kirkoff Hall is where the student is right next to Akram and student union is really part of the student center area there.
And I am going to my mailbox to pick up the mail the next day or so after this conversation with Norm Raskett. And I bump into me, Nichols. And I say, Steve, I'm thinking of going down to help out with snack.
I mentioned the John Poppy article, which he may have been the one to point out to me in the first place. It's possible. And I'm thinking of going down to Mississippi, make McNichols, says being Nichols, he says, well, terrific.
I said literally the words where I am thinking about right. He says, well, it turns out Sam Block and Charles McLaurin are going to be at the University of Religious Conference Center,
which is right next to the UCLA campus. They're going to be there tonight. And I'm helping out on their visit. My briefs, he had just been elected. This is down the spring. He had just been elected to NSA rap, he had civil rights credentials in the first place.
And he said, we can arrange a ride. And as I open my mouth, the young lady walks up where upon Steve turns to her and says, Rick is going to Mississippi to help. And I said to myself, speaking of myself, I said, my man, it looks like you're going to Mississippi.
So, I worked out. We made the arrangement. This is a world before cell phones and all the rest of it. But many of it somehow made Nichols prime these traps.
I would meet them again. This was in, I guess, late morning or early afternoon. And rendezvous again with them at the URC around Steve at around five or so on six, thirty or seven. It was a conference on civil rights to tell the story of what they were doing.
And these fellas were, I've already been told about me and were agreeable to it. And then, and then, and then, the McNichols says, there's some people you need to meet. And in addition to that, I'm going to do this. And so with a mutual friend, a man named Paul Albert, Steve knew it was a graduate student.
He's a very active and progressive and liberal and left causes. Originally out of Ohio, mature more mature since his thirties.
Grand Student Sociology Department, we go over to a party in the Hollywood Hills upon the election of a man named George E. Brown Jr, who had just been elected to Congress.
Early in the 62 elections of 63 and very newly elected City Council Member Tom Bradley. And the group of which Steve, to which it's referring me and the people hosting the party.
I mean, a variety of people got involved hosting parties. But the core of this party was Californians for Liberal Representation. These days, we'd probably call it Californians for progressive representation.
Which really quite a remarkable group of people, give an example. Two of Tom Bradley's first three deputy mayors came out of this The CLR-to-Bradley deputy-mayor pipeline.
Some years later, they may come to this party and introduce me. And with the idea that Congressman Brown might be willing to write a letter that I could have with me.
Saying I volunteer asked by him, written a letter, a letterhead observing voter registration practices in the South. The theory wasn't that it would do anything for me if I was in the hands of officials.
But rather, if I was in a situation where my life was in danger from people who were not officials, who might hesitate if they thought in some way I was federal.
And so George E. Brown Jr, who's rather remarkable man in puffing this cigar, is the whole UCLA connection. George E. Brown Jr. + Tom Bradley UCLA roommates and so on.
And the co-op. And the puffing is a guard. And all the rest of it nodding, he agreed. And sure enough, a week or so later, I'm in Mississippi and this letter arrives. He did take care of it and sent it.
And it made in some ways a bit helpful. Then I went with, so I went and stayed overnight. So let my folks know. I had the decency to my daughter pulls a stunt like this. I have a helper. But I'd call my folks and my mother remembers from Arkansas. She said, honey, not Mississippi.
But I went, well, a couple of other places too, including parts of Arkansas. But that was her quick reaction. And so I went down with them and arrived in Greenwood.
Did you ever been to Mississippi? When I arrived and showed up and it was a, you know, arrived three follows. We drove straight through. And Sam Block and Charles McLaurin really very remarkable, both African Americans, very remarkable organizers and leaders in their own way, even before the civil rights movement.
Sam Block was a well-known popular musician. Sam Block's band was going around to lots of dances and parties tremendously well-known all through Mississippi and African American circles. And a real extraordinary follow. He passed away some years ago out here in Los Angeles. But he's originally a native Mississippi. So none of them. And I showed up. And one of the, and one of the,
I was there for a bit of time and in Mississippi. And I remember, for example, going to church south of Greenwood, north of Canton, Mississippi, that small rural church and hearing and vivid terms, the Exodus story. And the promise land and getting to freedom and giving some sense of the world.
And special resonance to that wonderful song, go down Moses way down in freedom land and so on. All done deep in the, deep in the curriculum of what Baptists describe as the Old Testament and very powerful linkages to what had happened to the Jewish people, the Hebrew people in the Exodus and in the book of Exodus.
I can remember being going to a voter registration rally in the outskirts of Canton, Mississippi. And we're there. And about different people there about to have me say a few words. I was the white guy. I was the white person around.
This is the year before Mississippi freedom summer, 63. So I found myself sort of at this church and then about to do it here. So representing the fact that there are people who are allies that we care about in the north and in the west. You've got some port and so on and so forth. And I was careful to limit my remarks to a very few words.
But when I did speak briefly, and I was ready to speak again at this baseball, baseball field rally over on the third base site. And Willie Willie Wazir Peacock walked over to me and said before I spoke and other said time to go. Just walk. And so I don't look.
So we just walk towards cars and we got into cars and then I did take a peek coming around on the right field side on the first base side there. They were the Confederate flags flying, carload after carload after carload of guys and those cars and the crowd just it was late afternoon, dusk and early evening summertime.
Dusk and people just feeding away that we drove out of there and got on the road and drove on until the night and got back safely. But it was got some idea of the menace and so on. A little later.
I was going to ask you because you talked about driving with them across country to to me.
I was going to ask him when you mentioned driving across country to Mississippi. Just being in a car, guys of different races, could be quite challenging to see what that was.
We drove through without any of it. We didn't particularly stop. We highballed. I mean we're all driving pretty fast across Texas and across the South West. We just kept, kind of we just rolled through.
There was no, we stopped. We rolled in at Greenwood. It was dark. It was late. It wasn't. People were still in the office. 708 Avenue in. I remember visiting it.
After Rebecca and I married, we went back and visited it in 2008 just after the November election and went to that spot. You know how you remember certain addresses.
And the buildings gone but the footprints there. The stoop on where a lot of serious discussions were held. This cement stoop is right there. Oh yeah, lots of this was. When I say the snake off, I should modify that right away.
It was the Council of Federated Organizations, Kofo, which was SNCC and WACP Corps. And I may be leaving SNCC and WACP Corps SCLC.
I think everyone in the wisdom, I don't think it was this autumn, before I came along and my very minor figure anyway in that constellation of people.
But we can have our differences in New York and Washington, maybe even in Atlanta and other places. But down there, it's so serious. We better have a combined effort. And so it was a COFO operation. Now as a practical matter, fair number of the people there were snake. But for example, the man named Dave Dennis came in one day and he was with CORE, and so on.
And it didn't, I mean, everyone, it didn't, I mean, it may have been episodes of their places where these things were worked out. I wasn't there that long. But what I once era was consequential. I then moved me on to Georgia. But because I was literally bumped in, sleeping in the same bed with Lawrence, Lawrence Guyot.
And he was in charge of the office because Bob Moses was up in New England. And we got up. I remember it was kind of a house behind a house in Greenwood near the office.
And we were there and it would overstated to call out a safe house. But it was a hard place to find. They go in and start looking for people in that area. I know we were there. Probably the law enforcement knew perfectly well where we were. But the point, but the other hand, we weren't violating any laws, at least in the immediate sense.
And the, I remember, Lawrence Guyot got up and somehow it had a word that Mrs. Hamer had. You know, was he knew this when I was awakening. He got up before I did. So he had no cell phone. So he somehow maybe had been a phone in the location or someone came over to get him. And I didn't realize that.
But he said to me as I woke up and rub my eyes over. He said, I'm going to go bail out Mrs. Hamer, friendly little Hamer and some young ladies who were arrested over in Winona. And he, I started to say worst to the effect of do you want me to come along. I can't remember if I actually utter the words or not, but he was out the door.
And he drove over to get them. And we learned and did not come back right away, nor did they come with him. And we learned that when he arrived, they handcuffed him and beat the hack out on with baseball bats and broad daylight, little of a Sunday.
Right near Baptist Church, just beat him up baseball really and his head was swollen. They threw him in jail. I wind over up over in the office, been in the office. And now in charge is Willie Wazir Peacock. It was in Oakland, Willie Wazir Peacock.
And so I put myself in it. It was Wally and me. And then there was some drop off an age. I'm 23 at the time. Wazir Wally's about my age. So was Gia. Me and I'm being here together.
But you drop off pretty quickly to 19 year olds by Moses the way Sam Block was off somewhere else and so on. And I figure it's into it. So you do what you're asked to do. And so I did everything I'm saying I did right now. I did it the direction of Wally and we work very well together. And we essentially doing what he said.
Jats and Ian some brilliant ideas. One of which was we realized remember this is Mississippi in 1963. It's much closer to the Mississippi of 1955. I meant tell Mississippi of 1935 Mississippi of 1925 and so on. Then it was to Mississippi after after the Civil Rights Act, the Voting Act, much different.
And it was no effect. No local law enforcement presence on the FBI, the local FBI director. I happen to pick up a local paper running for state legislator. All white, Lily White primary.
And the bureau was not particularly interested in being involved in civil rights per se. There were much more interested in communist and the civil rights movement. So so far.
Oh, yeah. And so we had so in any event. We call a clause sitting of the New York Times at the time and also Karl Fleming at Newsweek.
Well, we divided up calls and called and first called Julian Bond. Excuse me. I have this backwards. He called Julian Bond and he called these two reporters. That's what it was. And they may have called into us. I remember some conversation. But now that I think about it, it was through Julian, it was communications director for Stick.
And seemed to be always available two in the morning, five in the morning at the middle of the day, Sunday through Sunday, you know, and so on and so forth. And very, very, very good at this because the main thing we had, the law enforcement, no particular federal president was some press interest.
And these folks called and then was here. Well, he asked me to do the thing that's me to call man, go Revers to see about another referee bail money. So I call Medgar Evers, who says, well, I remember worst of the fact of what Mr. Tuttle I will.
I have to go out now to a meeting. I'll call you when I get back. I'm just going out the door is very and he probably was thinking to himself as he reached for both of his kids and reach for a lot of door to go to his home. Well, I've got to call that follow back and up in the greenwood because of Fannie Lou Hamer and so and so forth. And it was then that by Randela back with murder.
So we then we and all hell breaks loose in Jackson.
That grabbers had become a major regional figure and some largely a national figure because he had been the voice of Mississippi, African Americans and the Tillbys, Emmett Till case, been NAACP director, etc.
And I miss Mississippi on the ground right in the heart of extremely dangerous and difficult plays in the murder.
Willie Willie Wazir Peacock gets another idea that we can't find or we don't think we can't seem to find where Fannie Lou Hamer are, the young ladies, June Johnson, the others who are weathered.
And now Gia and the danger was the thing we were worried about is there being moved around. Then every once responsible, no one responsible.
You wind up, people are dead and missing and now I'm sorry, and a jury can't decide, and DAs can't decide who to file against and so on.
I'm talking about including well-meaning people. The whole thing because the underlying structure and the chances are in a segregated, all lily white situation, you're going to get people to simply want this stuff excused and go on in life as usual.
So it's very, very dangerous. It turned out they were in the jail the whole time. We just didn't know it.
And we couldn't find it and the usual sources of information for one reason, other dried up. It was pretty good underground because generally white folks down there in that setting didn't realize that African Americans, at least is what we thought, could understand what they were saying and so on.
But that got shut down in which that itself was concerning, the normal conversation in front of people and so on and so forth.
So let me be gone suggested I call the governor. So I did. And we scripted and he scripted me. I explained just who I was. I'm quite new here. I'm a, I'm a, you see, I like graduate student from California. I'm here helping in the civil rights effort here.
He took the call. I went to when governor took the call and I said just what I said and said that we, I mean, go back a step after Medgar Evers died. All I started to say all hell broke loose in Jackson.
And that's the famous moment when John door or iconic moment goes down the, comes down the street holding up his credentials saying, I am John door from the United States Department of Justice.
So the, it's interesting because Medgar Evers in two ways, one I'll get to perhaps a little later, even in death continued to play a helpful role in the civil rights moment.
And in this case, in case of business hammer and the others as well, I pick out and I said to each other a year or so ago, we're talking about this. That's basically doing what we said. We kept them alive.
And it's again, it's hard to remember this, but people would disappear. There were people being shot. And for example, in the mega ever saying Mr. Deela back with didn't bother to wipe off his prints. He just put down the rifle went on about his business.
There were all sorts of stories about this. There was no legal remedy here and nothing. So in any event, we weren't sure what was going to happen there.
What did happen is they were being badly beaten and brutalized in the jail. They forced trustees, African American trustees, our prisoners to beat them.
So it's over. None of that. I did what exactly what Willie Willie Wazir Peacock suggested I called and did say to them, look, I'm here. I'm from who I am. I give them my name. Probably a wiretapper on here somewhere on this. And I'm probably more than one.
And we know that you've got your hands fall in Jackson. They pulled in everything. Fishing game wardens, highway patrol, everything they had because of these demonstrations, which were where Jackson was teetering on the edge of even more serious problem.
I said, what I can report to you is that if Mrs. Hamer and Lawrence Guyot and the others in their names and Annelle Ponder, June Jackson, a couple other people, if we're not notified where they are and how they can be, their release can be secured, there will be major demonstrations up here in the Delta. You're in Greenwood.
And so, parenthesis, he knew what I knew, what Dick Gregory had come out some months earlier and actually had been public activities around the civil rights in Greenwood.
And so the governor said to me, well, son, are you threatening me? I said, sir, I'm not threatening you. I'm new here. I'm simply reporting to you. I'm reporting what I'm told and I'm asked to call you. No, I'm not. I'm just telling you what's going to happen.
And I'll never know, probably never know for sure. Maybe you folks will find out as you go along or it'll become evident in some way or other.
But we had a timeline, a deadline on this. We need to know by such and such a time is later that day. And before that deadline, a couple hours later, the highway patrol, which last time I looked reports to the governor of state, highway patrol, called and indicated where they were.
They were at the jail. So, where we could go and get them bailed out. Andrew Young flew in. Andrew Young actually drove in. He had been at a conference. I think probably in Alabama and Burmiham. This I picked up from talking with him about it years, years, years later.
He came in and with bail money to go get them out. And I still remember this very tough situation. I know. And I still remember thinking the 23rd song that goes through the valley of the shadow of death as he, understanding everything got in car and drove over to.
I know and have to bail them out. And he has a whole story he tells about getting them out and he did and brought them back.
Meanwhile, word reached through this network. I'll use the term underground through reliable sources that Mr. Byron De La Beckwith, who was from Greenwood, which is where the co-fall off as well.
And it demonstrated his willingness and his capacity to do murder so that he was going to go kill the white boy. I was at white boy. So they realized that danger. And so they put me under a blanket after half a day, I guess, of discussing it.
And took me to Memphis, the airport, and flew to the SNCC office in Atlanta. And went in there. It's from there.
SNCC was, I went on to Chatham County, I went on to Savannah, but when I was in Atlanta, SNCC was always to its great credit pushing in those days, pushing the envelope.
And we've been a settlement reached by the Civil Rights organizations and the Atlanta authorities taking it easy in Atlanta on various civil rights activities, particularly lunch counter sit-ins and so on and so forth.
SNCC wasn't necessarily always part of that consensus. And so I was part of a group. I remember one day walking down to desegregate a lunch counter. I remember passing by, it was some distance.
I'd say a 40-50 yards away, but I had a clear line. I could see Lester Maddox out in front of his restaurant and he had a pickaxe handle. And he was out there. I don't remember if it was his emblem. I don't remember him specifically having the pickaxe handle, but I remember him having a visible figure pointing and gesturing and so on and so forth.
When I'm by to another restaurant and I remember we were at sit-in there and this is just a straight forward restaurant sit-in desegregation standing on the shoulders of the sit-ins in 1960.
And there we were. It was, remember, it was all before the 1964 Public Accommodation Act, Civil Rights Act. And I still remember pretty vivid in my mind. There's a line of black and white were there.
We're in Atlanta, not in Mississippi and not in rural Georgia. And a lady had this waitress who was so upset. Her whole world was being turned upside down. And she had this back of absolute boiling water.
And she was standing, I mean, lunch counter. And she's right here and she's above me, standing above me. I'm in my head's here and she's here with that lunch box. And there were African American here, African American here, white person here. She's standing right there.
And I looked at her and she was looking at me and she was extremely upset. Behind us were some reporters. And one of whom I'd run into, I'd gone to Wesleyan, he was a graduated Hosea Williams. Just that's bringing us in.
And he was named as John Kifner. And John Kifner was covering the Civil Rights Movement for the Berkshire Eagle, which is Berkshire, the Western Madison. And he later went on to a very distinguished guru with the New York Times.
As widely known as a reporter's reporter, we're talking Beirut, we're talking the Fred Hampton killing in Chicago on and on and on.
But he's standing there with us. I might back to him. So I take it. He was standing there with us. No pad and others. And it was a very long 45 seconds.
A voice at the far end said, all right, and he called her by name. All right, he said, now let's all settle down. And that police officer walked in, had a wrapped his, his baton down, turned to our picket captain and her. She stepped, gave her, she stepped back.
And he, he officer doing his duty. And he came in and he turned to whoever was in charge of us. And then there was a moment or two. Okay, do we? I, I wasn't in the command of this. I was doing what we wanted to do.
But I take it was not a day we were going to go to jail and take an arrest. And so we moved on and left. As we walk back, John Kifner said to me,
I'm going to put away my notepad. I'm going to join this effort. No, excuse me. That's not what happened. As we walked back, we talked about it. Wesleyan and William, small colleges, common ground, and so on.
When I'm back, very shortly thereafter, that conversation did not happen that way it happened in another place.
Went back to the SNCC office and there were marches going on in Chatham County, Savannah. And they, and the people in the SNCC office in Atlanta, one of whom was Casey Hayden.
Another of whom was Dicky Romley. Casey Hayden for sure. And I think Dicky Romley was the other. Talk to, to me, to Bruce Gordon, who might have met. I've been there a few days.
And also a man named Youngman, named Joe Iyer, who was 19 or so a student at Haverford College. Bruce was 23, Bruce's a year or so younger.
I've been in the military, not a little time at, I think CCNY. And then at, you know, more house or more sprouts, setting theater, but it would join the movement, African American.
And we had gotten acquainted in those few days around Atlanta and in size, so some and so on and so forth. And I said, what I like to say, you folks down to three of you down to Savannah.
There's a Southern Christian Leadership Conference of Philly at the Chatham County Crusade for voters, which has been carrying on demonstrations, Hosea Hosea Williams, the Hosea Hosea Williams, and Benjamin Van Clark, the very charismatic folks.
We think you folks might be able to help there, help them with some non-violent work and also just be supportive in various ways.
So we drove from Atlanta, one of these things you do it to do it, you just go do it. So we drive down to Savannah, Bruce Gordon and Joe Iyer.
And so we drove down there and I remember we arrived at night, there at church in Savannah. And a place was packed. And they have been doing these night marches.
This is for desecrification of the public facilities, me, restaurants, hotels, the desoto hotel there and other things, employment issues, so on.
The voter registration was more than most places. I'm not saying it was as good as it should have been, but the Chatham County Crusade for voters actually Mr. Hosea Williams,
life had run for a county commission, I believe it was. And that was an electoral campaign a year or two earlier, hence the Chatham County Crusade for voters.
They were some variants for the NAACP chapter there, which is working in its own manner. But Hosea Hosea Williams and Benjamin Van Clark and others were,
had mobilized very major night marches. So we arrived and here's this walk in and there's this spellbinding oratory from Reverend, he became a Reverend, Reverend Hosea Williams,
a chemist of the agricultural department, World War II, badly wounded, left for dead, came back and was beaten up as a serviceman, one of these servicemen in the 40s, 1945ers, beaten up coming off a train or bus upon returning to service, etc.
But anyway, a remarkable man and he had gotten his college degrees at one of the Atlanta colleges and the child of a man named Blind Tom and another lady, and just a remarkable guy, terrific individual and children and so on and so forth.
But worked for the U.S. government and the chemist and department, and Benjamin Van Clark, who was a terrific, recently out of high school student leader.
I still remember the scenes when it was more than once, but that night was the first time I saw it. I said, all right, now we're about to go on on the march and we all know what will happen.
In terms of discrediting us, if weapons were found on anyone, so please put your things in these baskets, they pass you on these baskets.
And there was the clatter and clink of brass knuckles and sappers, oh god, I don't know how I've switched blades.
But think of the political consciousness that time.
Think of the commitment to sober rights and what that meant, but they were willing to do.
And people were willing to forego that normal things that one carries and self-defense and so on and so forth.
And so off we go on the marches and we're quite off, quite regularly.
And mass, what are called mass meetings in these churches.
And we go on to, we stay at a place we go upstairs.
I didn't particularly notice the person I did to where we're staying.
And then Donna, I mean, the place we're staying is a house of prostitution.
And it's something that I've thought about a good deal since.
And that is what you have, the ladies were there.
They knew who we were, the we acknowledge each other.
They see them and we're upstairs.
But this was a pro bono thing.
The owners were doing this as part of the movement.
And furthermore, on occasion, we're actually putting their places of business up his bail money.
Risking them.
It's really quite remarkable to think about it a bit.
And the, after, so after a few days of marching, one of the most darnful things I've done or agreed to do,
is they came to me, the leadership came to me, Benjamin Van Clark, who said, well Rick, remember I've been out there marching.
And one of two or three whites.
And one of two to be literal about it.
And these marches are all kinds of cameras.
All those public marches.
And click, click, click, like eyes or locales from the flash bulbs and so on.
And this are that journalist security people, others.
And plus, these people found it interesting.
So there we are.
And they say, well, we're going to have you engage quarters away from here.
And we're going to go to white supremacist meetings, to public meetings.
So I go and agree to it.
And I get a place to stay.
And you have some questions, what do you do during the day?
I mean, what do you do at your time?
I saw by by Birdie.
So often.
I kept going to the same movie over and over.
There are two shows that, and there's a library there.
And I would basically tuck myself in and then go to the meetings,
which were on the outskirts of Savannah in Chatham County.
And would, another thing about I don't remember how I got there.
I may have walked.
I may have taken buses.
I don't remember exactly how I did, but I did.
And was these were not, you know, tiny secret conglysies for public meetings,
held by people whose world was turning upside down.
Was it a plan or was it?
One of the meetings, one of the meetings was planned, public plan meeting, possibly two.
The others were white supremacist meetings.
Committed to segregation.
There was a, people would be introduced here and there who were introduced as the deputy,
you know, our good friend so and so was with the police departments, etc.
You know, some of that going on and so on.
Here I am in these crowds having marched around publicly for several days.
And, but the assignment essentially was to have a year there, have eyes and ears there,
and let the folks know in the civil rights movement, if numbers to call, things like that.
There was any imminent risk or threat or anything else.
I got no serious information.
At some point they basically said, why don't you, you know, we try that.
Okay, now let's come on back in.
So I came on back in into the civil rights back to the place where I was staying, back into the office.
And it was there for a few days and then one night and it happened to be a night only time I was there where I was sick.
I just got good old fashioned sick for a day.
So I slept in that day all night, all hell broke loose in Savannah.
A fire broke out, someone burned a building, things got out of hand.
The context was, Jose O'Ea was Benjamin Van Clark and the others were all being thrown in jail.
So there was no real leadership in the Savannah structure.
Oh, by the way, it's something I need to come back to.
A day after we arrived John Kifner shows up and says, after what happened in that restaurant, I've decided my place is not to be a reporter but to join in this effort.
And he did.
And Kifner put away his reporter's notebook and made it clear he was part of our effort.
So he was also part of our group.
It'd come in and say that summer.
Not even.
We all hell broke loose.
The governor indicated he'd be calling out the National Guard.
A day or so later, Andrew Young, Andrew Young and James Bevel, James Bevel, come to Savannah.
So there in the office, I am now in the office of the Chatham County Crusade for Voters.
And with these fellows and all of a sudden there's sort of, and a couple other people in the South of India, kind of a commotion of the door.
Voices raised for a minute.
Then income.
Several police officers from Savannah Police Department.
They walk up to me.
I'm behind the desk.
I happen to be standing behind the desk, phoning.
Where I may have stood up and they came out.
I'm on the phone with someone.
And I get off the call and they walk up to me and say, you're under arrest.
We have a warrant for your arrest.
I said, could I, at that moment I realized I had one major assignment.
Say what?
The major assignment was for them not to realize who else was in the room.
They picked me up. That's one thing. They picked up Andrew Young and James Bevel.
They picked up two of Dr. King's, Big Five or six.
Ralph A. Reverend, Avernathy, Andrew Young, Jesse Jackson's not yet on the staff.
James Bevel who had done Birmingham and Andrew Young when we went to the earlier saw.
Andy and I did see how the corner of my eye for a moment.
A Reverend, a Reverend, a Andrew Young.
Got very interested in the floor.
As they were sort of walking away, easing themselves away.
And I say, well, I want to see the warrant.
They pull out of people.
I said, I don't see my name.
I said, there it is, John Doe, white.
I say, my name is Rick Tonnell.
I said, that's good enough for us son.
And so they cuffed me and it takes me out.
And I stay south of being obstreparous.
But north of being so docile that they have started to look around the room.
And they have their job, which is to get me out of there.
They take me out down the stairs.
And as I go down the stairs, reporter from United Press who knew who I was is coming up the stairs.
He sees me.
I think to myself, oh my poor mother.
So we get in the car and they take me down into the jail and pull through the process.
And I remember that night.
I had enough sense to keep my clothes on.
They put me in solitary.
So I've been solitary.
It was light on my face.
It's black.
And I hear a voice, a disembodied voice saying, I'm not in the clan.
Hey, Baba, wake up.
I'm not in the clan.
I was sort of wake up on my own pace.
I'm not in the clan, but I'm awake.
And I was sitting up.
I looked at me, sort of, rucked and looking at a nice tight crew cut.
I'm not in the clan.
But my brother is.
So I, and I happened to know that night the clan was marching in Savannah.
I mean, a big night march on top of what had just happened.
Right.
The governor's all over the place on the governor's standard.
And so they keep me there in solitary for a bit.
They bring us down to court.
And they had me in there along with, I'm going to use the term 40, number 45.
It could be off.
It may have been 41 or 49, somewhere in the 40s.
Other civil rights people, including Hosea Hosea Williams.
And much of the structure of the Chatham County Crusader Voters, SCLC operation.
So we went to, represented by James Nabrit III who is father's,
probably been president Howard University, Howard University Law School.
And they advised us to not be sworn.
You could give unsworn testimony or else they'd come after us on burgery charges.
So once we were so far, so we gave unsworn testimony, which put in the record.
So we did.
And the judge was, Judge Victor Mullen, who in his own ways are very remarkable.
Man, he's blind, completely blind, since apparently, since childhood.
And was raised as a very strong, talismage faction part of Georgia politics.
And was a segregationist and so on.
And meanwhile, what he had done, he was using, and something he thought of,
made it clear he had thought of it this time past.
Peace bonds, where they get people to swear out complaints and have bonds issued,
where then you have to put up property in order to be released from custody.
To what I was doing or others like me are doing is disturbing their peace.
It's not a disturbing the peace charge.
It's disturbing the peace enough so that a peace bond is issued.
They used to be used in domestic disputes and one kind or another.
And what he did is he put on bail terms that were very onerous.
And I think about it for a minute. Savannah is a city of about what, 200, 300,000.
And he would stack the charges for stack.
So I had seven peace bonds for him.
He was saying, Hosea Williams had seven or eight and so on.
Each one he required unencumbered property.
And you just didn't have enough.
Right.
And so what you de facto had done was 49 or 49 or 45 or 50 people.
And then someone would be let out, and I'll say be let out, then they put them back in.
I'd pick the charges again.
Anyway, what I recall is that the gentleman who was the one who was in court who gave testimony
that I had disturbed his peace, he himself was an older gentleman and couldn't identify me in the courtroom.
Plus I had not been there.
But even across the courtroom and so on and so forth.
Anyway, so I go back in later Ronald Goldfarb,
who's made something of a reputation for himself years ago as expert on bail and preventive detention and this sort of thing.
That fall was lecturing at the Yale Law School and a friend of mine, Peter Dibwad, who had gone to Wesleyan acquaintance of mine,
as he put it dozing in the back and Ronald Goldfarb is discussing onerous bail by cases.
Peter describes that he woke up to the fact that my name is mentioned as part of this case.
Well, they kept me for a while in the solitary.
It turned out not far away was Hosea Hosea Williams.
I realized he was there but we were careful to speak to each other because we didn't know how it was standing there listening.
We couldn't see so and so forth.
And then they put me in the white cell block.
So I went into the white block and across a wire screen and across on the other side were the prisoners in the jail who were African-American, the males.
The young ladies were upstairs.
And including Bruce Gordon, who had been thrown in.
Also, he'd been picked up on one of these things.
So I'm there and coming into the jail where I wasn't quite sure what would happen but I had a pretty good idea.
Because I'm in there and there are put and fellows in there who pick up on car, you know, on car theory, drunk driving.
Very busy there, late Friday night, Saturday.
And the ass.
And I was in fairly good shape.
It turned out I do a lot of push ups and all this sort of stuff.
And it was pretty fit.
You see I had finished second in the inner Moral 400 meters of 440 and third in the 880 and so on and so forth.
I had a lot of walking and all that business.
To endless one hour push ups and all this stuff.
And so I, so these guys never touched me.
And some of them did particularly like what I was doing.
So we're right. What's all this?
I later learned, I was still there.
Bruce told me later.
By later I mean we were still in custody but we could speak to each other through the grading wire.
We were two things. They spread the rumor.
But I was one vicious gang banger on a New York and don't mess with me.
I'm really not sure how plausible that was.
Who's the real life where they did the several rights.
But what also happened was, and it's really quite a remarkable story.
Not unlike what I mentioned earlier about the houses that put up their bail money and so on.
The trustees.
These are guys doing an easy time.
These are the people who get the cigarettes, get the candy.
They can go out on the coast, they go across the street, bring it back, pick up newspapers.
They're called bridge boys.
They wore a rather distinctive outfit.
They're in jail.
One of them was Felian Popeye who was a well-known Welterweight boxing class.
And members of Anna's a port town.
So long shore union, green shops and steward.
It's a nice strong tough, great guy.
Very friendly to me.
And what apparently he and the others did as they said to the white guys is they came through and they stripped searching.
And they're given them the usual stuff.
When you're going into jail body cavity, all the rest of it said, listen, you leave this guy alone.
He's with us.
And you touch him.
And we're going to beat the hell out of you.
Now think about that for a minute.
They have easy time.
They're willing to put it on the line.
And they segregated corrections, you know, jail situation.
And they're credible guys in terms of following up this threat to anyone who would mess with me.
A relative stranger.
I mean, they accept them off civil rights.
They can wind up in a state prison farm.
And that's hard time.
They certainly wouldn't be trustees.
They were willing to roll that out and put that on the line.
If they come out with that, Matt, too.
We decide after a while because we have some communication back and forth quite a bit of it.
Because they're right there graded to African-American civil rights prisoners.
They're plenty of other people in the jail, but they had in that area everyone being held.
We decide, Bruce Gordon, I think it was Bruce who thought of the idea.
And that is two, we're not criminals.
We're not people doing something that's good.
And we're going to do everything we can to act that way.
And so I'm 99% sure of this is Bruce's idea.
Might be someone else mentioned them.
We're going to run a freedom school.
So I wound up teaching history.
He taught theater arts.
Someone else taught mathematics.
And we had these little clusters of people going the day.
And it was very interesting, the impact on the guards.
They began to see this.
It was interesting.
There was another thing that happened as well.
But this one on a bit, et cetera.
And meanwhile, the efforts, my mom and dad,
my mom, he said there.
And so they were attempting to represent to the judge.
The judge had it in his mind.
Remember, in from Mississippi, who am I?
I'm 23, I'm not 19.
He had it in his mind.
I was something fairly big time.
He wasn't sure what exactly, but I was pretty big time.
So I'm there.
And when I had been out at UCLA, one of the things I did on Sundays,
I'm raised to Piscopayon and Mathenist,
was go to Canterbury, which is the Episcopal.
In fact, it raised some money from to go to help finance my trip.
I ran around for half a day or a short time.
It may have been that very afternoon, I can't remember.
But Ray and Father Crowder + Aaron Buchsbaum, who was the Episcopal priest on campus,
had made some phone calls, raised some cash from the Presbyterians,
from others, from me, I mean, and for me, from Episcopalians,
the Methodists, and so on, University of Religious Conference people,
to help underwrite my trip.
And down there in the experience, I just wonder,
he had been involved in the fraternity fight.
He had blasted the fraternities and sororities for segregationist practices.
At about the time, we were involved back east.
That's some fellowship.
Well, he later wound up Bishop of Kimberley,
got thrown out by the apartheid regime.
He's going to a national conference in Toronto.
I'm being represented to the court as a fairly harmless person.
He shows up, where out there shows up to bless me,
he's on his way, give me communion, and to be part,
and to be, and to do everything he could,
to be sure I wasn't being mistreated.
And a little later, Congressman Brown sends down George E. Brown Jr,
sends down a couple of aid.
So the judge is saying back to his people,
wait a minute, yes, yes, and then there's another episode
where the, well meanwhile, so I'm, are we rolling now?
So, okay, sir.
Okay, so I'm in, I'm sitting there in custody,
and so are all the others.
We have these bail terms that are very tough,
and no one's quite figured out how to solve them.
And Hosea Hosea Williams also in custody,
he's not in the main block they have in Wilmer's solitary near where I had been,
then he was out, then he got out.
And it was also a distinct possibility that a major effort would be mounted in Savannah.
It was a summer where lots of people went to jail.
Tom Hayden in his memoir actually took the trouble to have the research center did it himself,
and so the number of people who went to jail in that 1963 period,
it was the Birmingham, bracketed by Birmingham over here in May,
and the March on Washington, followed by the bombing of the killing of the children in Birmingham,
and the church that was blown up.
Dynamite, and none of that, a lot of people, a lot going on.
And we thought we might get relief from the Fifth Circuit,
a court of appeals, a problem in Senator (Russell B.) Eastland was talking about splitting the court judicial chair.
And so the court was hesitant to come involved,
to come involved, that presiding justice had the same last name I do,
Elbert Parr Tuttle, so there was always a little sense I might be related, I made it there, I wasn't.
But I get asked that from time to time, and any of them.
And the NAACP Legal Defense Fund was spread out all over the South, all over the place, or something.
So my folks, hustle word is, I'm, hey, there are very few people who meet whites there,
be it my dad is with the National Aeronautics and Space Administration as the Education Program Director,
and it becomes, you know, a minor but significant way for early newsworthy,
this follows here and so on and so forth.
And I've been perfectly aware of the fact when I went down,
that part of the assignment of whites who went on there is to do what we're told,
of civil rights people, and to work with them at the same time,
perfectly aware of the fact that if we draw fire, we're going to get a lot more attention to the cause,
than a lot of other people would understand that.
And any of that, the, the, um,
dad and mom were reaching out to,
see, to do whatever they could,
and word had gone to New Haven, Connecticut, back to New Haven,
that, you know, Fred Toddle, Fred Mary, Emily Son,
is in jail down there in Savannah, and so on,
the word reached Izzy Waxler, who was head of the Anti-Defamation League,
a B'nai B'rith in Southern, Southern Connecticut.
And he and dad, and looking at my father's diary,
that I realized this, he and dad both as men in their mid-30s,
back to what I was saying earlier, dad went into the Marine Corps,
and Izzy into the Army in the Hitler War,
and there were two men with families, both 33, 34, 35,
36 years old, took a while to get in,
and they got into the Warn 44,
and trying to get into the war.
And so a lot of people did join,
um, good buying, good luck parties to them around New Haven.
They knew each other, liked each other,
were very close to one another anyway, educators and so on.
And so this fit, this fit, very,
as it got explained, to be very appropriately into a sense of,
well, these fights go on, one or another, fight against fascism,
fight against segregation, fight against this and that, the other day.
Anyway, Izzy contact, they use his contacts to reach,
um, the Anti-Defamation League Network in Atlanta,
who in turn, reached Dr. William "Bill" Waxler, same spelling,
but no relation, who had been on Alderman in Savannah,
and a very prominent individual, and a doctor there,
and Dr. Waxler, um, through another track,
people in, in, um,
in Northern New York and Placbridge,
or Bornstein, reached out to his ADL contacts,
and a very good friend of the family,
and reached Aaron Buchsbaum, who was an attorney in Savannah,
starting a business practice, two small children,
graduated from Emory, and meanwhile,
co-incident with that Stephen S. Trott, who I mentioned earlier,
Hiveman, Harvard Law School, was over at, um,
major firm in Cincinnati, that had Proctor and Gamble as a client,
so on and so forth, at least I assume they did.
And, um, Trott was from a P&G family,
and so a Sally, and co-incidently, also reached Aaron Buchsbaum,
had a person reach Aaron Buchsbaum,
someone who said, well, Aaron, this isn't my cause,
someone in Atlanta, but I know you're interested in civil rights
based on our conversations at law school.
Turned out, Aaron Buchsbaum and Dr. William "Bill" Waxler were, uh,
family members who marriage in Savannah,
and Aaron Buchsbaum agreed to represent me,
and William Waxler to put up his property,
that a stranger in a strange land, use a phrase.
So, I, um, my deal was, I don't go out unless everyone comes out,
and they said, fine, we get that,
your case, so we'll create the precedent for it,
because we're gonna go to another judge,
and instead of having to put up seven pieces of property,
put up one piece of property, and so on and so forth,
and, et cetera.
And they, um, so at that point, they come and see me.
I'm cautious because I'm not quite sure who these folks are.
I, I don't know, did not know then what I know now.
I was cautious, polite, and, uh, careful.
It turned out it was fine, they were both terrific.
When, um, the, uh, it turned out that when, um,
Aaron Buchsbaum came and it represented me,
and he said, he said, worst of the effect of, uh,
I can, I'm told I can bring you a book.
What book would you like?
I said, how about The Rise and Fall of the Third Reich?
And, he said, got it.
Plus, it's a nice thing, but, so, uh, the, um,
not a ring one more time, then it'll stop.
I meant to turn it off.
And then, um, uh, so I know he was now engaged,
and one, but one day he calls, um, my folks,
or regions, my folks, and said, watch out for this new story.
And I'd seen the same thing.
I turned out I got the local papers and the Atlanta Constitution.
They were, a story was moving across the Constitution,
a front page, a page three, that the Chatham County Crusade for Voters,
office where I had been arrested, where the Civil Rights Movement was in the office,
apparently for a nominal rent, maybe a dollar or something,
or a free of the International Union of Mine, Mill, and Smelter Workers,
which had been thrown out of the, uh, CIO in 1947,
during the days after the Taft-Hartley Act was passed,
uh, as a Communist Control Union.
And, I saw this, and wasn't sure,
if I could trust my own judgment, but Aaron Buchsbaum also saw it
with somewhat more independent eye, and both of us had the same reaction.
And that is, it looked like the way this story out of Atlanta was,
which was normally the Constitution's approach to civil rights papers.
And the other hand, there's a great fear about the Communists being involved in the Civil Rights Movement,
and they're also, the trajectory of the story was aimed at me.
Was it just that I saw it, Aaron Buchsbaum saw it,
independent of me, contacted my folks and said,
I don't like the way this story is unfolding,
because one day it passed, and two days it passed, so it was over.
And the, the reaction of the Civil Rights people in the Chatham County was,
well, we don't know about this Taff Tartley, or, you know, this,
that was in the 40s, this is early 60s, and so on.
And I think that is probably a true.
But any of that, but here's this, who is this fellow,
and he's coming in at Mississippi and all that,
and you can't remember the things specifically said Mississippi,
but who is this guy?
And it's starting to develop.
So dad calls Bruce Corwin (Metropolitan Theatres CEO) + Sherrill Corwin Sr.
There's kind of a collective phone call going on here.
And Bruce reaches, Bruce and his father are very engaged in this.
Bruce, Bruce, Victor M. Carter, a blessed memory,
and Sherrill Corwin Sr, a blessed memory, who had been the chair of the campaign
of Stanley Mosk for Attorney General.
And Stanley Mosk is the Attorney General, Edmund G. "Pat" Brown Sr was governor,
Stanley Mosk with Attorney General California.
And on there, say so, Stanley Mosk writes a letter to the Attorney General
of Georgia called the Solicitor General, which says to the Attorney General
of Georgia, copy to the Atlanta Constitution.
Rick Tuttle is not a communist.
I've known him.
I have family friends who've known him since he was in a fraternity together.
You may not agree on what he's doing in terms of promoting integration.
So he writes, I do, but this man is no communist.
Young man is no communist.
He is a, and so on, and so forth.
And the, and the, but another thing happened.
My mother called her girlfriend.
Her girlfriend, and she had been married the same summer.
She, to my, my mother to my father, down in Arkansas.
And my, and this lady had married a man named Frank Cherry, Frank Cherry.
Frank Cherry went on to become governor of Arkansas before (Orval) Faubus and so on.
He then, he was a Truman loyalist against the Strom Thurmond,
you know, in the Strom Thurmond.
I was a big dividing line in the South.
He was appointed head of the subversive activities control board of the United States.
And he called the publisher and said knock it off.
The story died.
You got, don't touch him.
Right.
You got the wrong guy.
Any idea where that story was coming?
Who was pushing that to begin with?
I don't know.
In fact, something I've not done has gone back.
I've gotten a little curious.
That interview we had a while back when I was at the state conference.
And thinking about this one's gotten me.
I've basically, except for that time and one other time,
I haven't really sat around and reminisced much about this.
But it's stirred my curiosity to go back and pull those, which I can do.
I'm going to pull those old files and have a look at it.
But it, I, I might have a better idea later.
But then it, I'm just giving you a contemporary, a recollection of contemporary events.
And any event, what happened was the, which all gets to the point of what allies can do.
Because I was bringing to the table.
I'm just doing what I'm told by the subversive people.
But bringing to the table a constellation of forces that was really rather considerable.
And I suppose was part of the insight that the Civil Rights leadership had,
both the SNCC and other places, in terms of freedom, summer, the next summer.
I'm not saying they modeled it on something I did.
But there was probably enough of us doing this here and there to suggest that the benefit might outweigh the cost.
I have no idea what, how others in the SNCC office, SCLC and NAACP saw it.
And the following summer, the, the scope project, the Dr. King,
and put on his one to put people in there.
But when I was there, they were very, very, relatively few of us.
But it was accomplishing part of what I intended, which is to raise consciousness,
get people discussing at the dinner table, everything else,
whether to get involved in Fred Tuttle's son and Mary Emily's son, all this sort of stuff, etc.
And they, well, then we went to Mr. Aaron Buchsbaum, Aaron Buchsbaum,
and Mr. Waxler, and whether I was here, went to another judge in Savannah,
who made the rulings we had hoped for, and also,
and then, also, there was also part of a package that arranged that the others also got out of J. Ellis,
while they went back in. His name was, I think of the court's name in a minute.
He was very nice. He saw me, he was a native of Savannah,
and he said to me after the proceedings, after he'd ordered my release, Dr. Waxler's,
or was there to provide his property bond. He took me aside and said,
I'm sorry about all this, what's happened. He didn't have to say that to me.
It was very, very nice of him to say it. The others got out,
and I, meanwhile, went back up north, I was part of the deal, am I getting out,
that I would leave the area, and I would risk his property,
because Judge Mullen would go after it. Oh, yeah, I could risk his math.
I gave my word, that I would not cause any trouble in Savannah, and it was over.
It was September, early September. I came back up north, and everyone got out.
In jail, not only a bit of...
What was the original charge?
It was these seven-piece bonds. That was in her, each of us,
that we had disturbed the peace under a Georgia statute,
disturbed the peace of the people who had sworn out these.
Apparently, Judge Mullen had made no secret of it. He invited this procedure.
As he saw it from his point of view, he was quieting things down,
and took this on. Savannah, standing on the shoulders of what happened,
because Jose Winslow's now out, had been out for a while.
Through a variety of techniques, before the Suburite Sack passed,
Savannah became the first city in the South to desegregate.
They had a biracial committee, everything else.
I also want to be clear and fair about this.
The mayor of Savannah Malcolm Maclean, was widely regarded as a moderate.
He had beaten the other faction sometime earlier, but the other thing
is that it's important to say this, and that is in the context of my being in custody
in the Chatham County, jail, the comments of that follow-not,
was standing about his brother being in the clan and so on and so forth.
I got a good deal of negative attitude from some people.
There were some of the guards who were okay.
And there were two things I saw that in embryos,
he suggested some shift of attitude.
One was the reaction to these freedom schools,
where you could sense it even among the more hard-line guards of a look of a kind of respect.
There was a second thing that happened.
I was in custody.
I was there for a month and a half.
And I was in custody when the March on Washington took place.
But we could hear it upstairs on the third floor.
We could hear the television. We could hear it. We couldn't see it.
And I was released a few days later, but in September.
But I detected a shift on the part of everybody
because after the March on Washington,
there was some recognition began to settle in that the civil rights side might win.
It might get civil rights legislation passed.
There certainly no great grounds for hope for quite a considerable period of time.
Things were pretty modeled up and everything else.
But that was important. That March was important.
Back to Mr. Evers for a minute,
without making too much of this point,
even in death,
Magga Evers was helpful in terms of the release of the governor of Barnett Funkall.
We know you got your hands full in Jackson.
And we're prepared or I can report to you that there will be demonstrations here in Greenwood
and have someone bonus, and so on.
And the other thing was, I've always felt this,
that when I went over to Atlanta,
one of the things we did a day or so after,
they got me out,
is we all went down to the train station and organized crowds to come down and gather people
as the funeral train of Magga Revers came through.
And I think one of the ways in which the March on Washington, I'm stretching a point,
but I'm going to go and say it because I've over the past few years,
one of the things that helped make the March so successful,
where people came in from all over the country,
including coming up from the South.
Some came in from California,
but most people came in the Eastern time zones in the South and North,
as people began to help to create the organizational structures
and the relationships in the context.
It's all before Twitter and all before email and all before cell phones and everything else,
but the relationships to gather on this funeral cartage going up to Washington,
the relationships that were rather shortly afterwards,
those same networks would have been deployed to gather people to Carpool,
get on trains, buses, and poor into Washington for the March.
And I've always felt that I've never mentioned it to Mrs. Evers,
but it occurs that I'm going to send her a letter because the 50th is coming up,
then to send her a letter to capture them.
And any of them, and I came back out to California,
and then we remained involved in some things.
Why don't I pause for a minute and give you a chance to?
We'll probably take a second to close the file.
We'll probably start to wind down, but maybe towards that end,
as you're starting to tell us a little bit about what you did then,
or what was...
Well, I came back out here, and one of my better decisions that I made when I got back
was not to become one of these people that was sitting around the college campus
and endlessly tell these stories.
I've told them the SNCC conference, but it was Rebecca,
I passed away, and then I was able to get Rebecca to marry me,
who after we married in 2008, we went back to the Civil Rights sites,
went back to Winona, Mississippi, which I never visited,
but certainly had been engaged with Savannah,
I mean to Greenwood, went down to Canton, Mississippi,
and then I, family in Mississippi, went to visit them near Philadelphia, Mississippi,
and then went across the South to Savannah,
and actually saw the jail cell where I had been,
because that's now part of (former) Chatham County Jail, Savannah GA.
And they, you can look in, and these are all artists,
I actually saw the place I was, and then we went over to Atlanta,
and arrived by coincidence in the coincidence
at opening of the Joseo Hosea Williams collection.
He is a library at the library in Atlanta,
whose name will come back to me in a minute,
so well known, predominantly African American collections.
And it's on tip of my tongue.
And any of it, his family, those of his remaining family members
were there as children, as a little coincidence.
When we were in Savannah, we arrived, and early before coming across,
and it turned out that there was a pictorial collection of Savannah
that, that summer of 63, and Aaron, Mr. Aaron Buchsbaum,
and his lovely wife Astor, were available for dinner,
and it turned out they told us that the, there was this exhibit
showing at Telfair Museum.
It was, I think, sponsored by the University of Georgia.
We went, we walked in, and there are pictures from that summer,
from those marches, but Benjamin Van Clark, and Trash Brownlee,
and Joseo Hosea Williams, and so on, and there were several quotes up,
and there were two quotes from Rick Tuttle,
which probably, for almost anyone in Georgia,
would raise a perfectly natural question of who is Rick Tottel.
But there I was, it was really quite a, there's a book out on this now,
I have very, very well-appointed book.
One of the interesting moments in my life, we were in Greenwood,
and at 708 Avenue N, Greenwood Mississippi, and at that moment,
I realized how little we've done in terms of dealing with truly deep poverty
in the North American United States.
One of the more moving moments I had a few minutes later,
after leaving the place where the COFO (Council of Federated Organizations) office had been,
where I'd been when I went to Mississippi, we went to a store,
are we looking around for people of an age where they might,
you know, have some memories together, and spend some time together,
and some workmen pointed this in the direction of a store or blocker.
So, away, we went over to the store, and as we pulled up,
we were driving a rental car, good looking black rental car.
It's about five years ago, I hopped on on one side,
and we're back up looking very fit, hopped on on the other,
and it probably was hard to tell just exactly who we were,
but there's always a possible, who knows who we were.
We come popping out on the car, and there's a group of young men
and African American young men on the corner,
and they begin to move away from it very carefully.
They don't know who we are, what we're doing.
We walked into the store, and it turned out it was a lady there
who had been around. She'd been a young lady,
14, 15-year-old lady, around the COFO (Council of Federated Organizations) office, the SNCC office.
And the next thing we were all singing,
was a little bit of a white song, as her sister was there,
someone else in this little general store.
And a couple of the fellows who've been outside came in
to buy a cigarette, you know, buy one cigarette at a time,
and they get the picture.
And when we walked out, the warmth of their receptions,
weren't the most moving experience that I've had ever.
But back to 1963, came out, and what happens a little later,
is we form a group on UCLA campus,
and near the religious conference center of the YMCA,
the Student Coordinating Committee,
and engaged ourselves in a two-pronged effort.
Bob Singleton was a co-chair of it, and Russell H. "Russ" Ellis Jr,
who's head of campus, core me.
And we visited ourselves in the fight for fair housing,
the No on Proposition 14.
We registered every weekend, we'd mobilize over 100 UCLA students.
And on Election Day, we had over 900.
We lost the referendum, eventually one of the courts.
A major mobilization.
And we also were in effect a Friends of Stick Group.
We did all sorts of things to generate support,
including working with Paul Albert,
McNichols, and others.
No matter how much you're Steve, it directly involved with us.
He's over in the Civil Rights Division of NSA,
in part of this time.
But we worked to attempt to persuade Congressmen, Augustus F. "Gus" Hawkins,
African-American Congressmen of South L.A.,
Congressman Phil Burton from San Francisco,
and Congressman William Fitts Ryan of New York, Manhattan,
and the Reform Democrat, to hold hearings in Mississippi.
So we had all sorts of letters sent.
We had people send it from their home addresses,
and we'd get other people to send them in law and behold.
They went and did it.
This all at the time, when we were just trying to...
The Congressional Committee, some cells,
weren't going to do it.
They're under the firm leadership of white segregation
as southern chairman, in most cases.
Not every case, but in most cases.
But these folks went and did it, and that helped a bit.
We did all sorts of things, and were involved there.
And then, of course, the connection between the Civil Rights Movement
and the UC Berkeley Free Speech Movement
is powerful.
Jack Weinberg was raising money from Mississippi, and so on.
We very much joined that effort and became deeply involved
in those struggles.
Sometime later, we became involved in a number of us,
and the campaign of James Jones,
who was the first African-American male to be elected
as a Board of Education, to a NAWA campaign,
which led into the Tom Bradley 1969 mayoral campaign (lost) + 1973 mayoral campaign.
After the death, and I met my first wife,
who lost a cancer some years ago,
in the campaign of the late Senator Robert F. Kennedy.
We were very involved in that.
We'd run into John Lewis, and we're deeply involved
in those efforts.
And like a lot of people of that generation,
we had five assassinations in less than five years.
The combination of Mr. Ebers, Michael Ebers,
President Kennedy, Malcolm X, Dr. King, Senator Kennedy.
So, just in there, the unified conspiracy that I'm confident
there was a conspiracy to kill Dr. King.
Clearly, to me, James Earl Ray never could have done that.
Logistically, the things he did with a lot of support,
logistics, finance, other things.
And then to wrap up, we were four,
Councilman Tom Bradley for mayor, I think, before he was.
He saw the data from the Kennedy campaign and saw,
we played a big role in this.
We were able to get a larger turnout of African-American voters
and Latino voters, partly with help with the (United) Farm Workers.
And Tom Bradley looked at that and realized that in a city
that's 13 or 14 percent locked, that you could get a turnout.
There might be 18 or 19 percent with the right candidate.
We had shown it in the 68 campaign,
and the standing on the shoulders of that.
He realized he can make a plausible campaign for mayor.
He did, to lost the first time we came back.
And one of the second time, I went on to be assistant
and associate team of two activities at UCLA.
I'm not under the Hatch Act of 1939, I mean very involved in politics
and movements, very close to the fire worker effort.
And then the (UFW grape) boycotts and so on and so forth.
I was a member of the L.A. Community College Board for two terms.
I played a role in getting the labor study center established there,
for example, one on, I was elected four terms
as Los Angeles City Controller.
And some of the fights we were engaged in were taking in the mandate
of that office fairly broadly.
One of them was to be able to lead the way to get an ordinance passed
to prohibit discrimination in the The Jonathan Club + The The Jonathan Club + The California Club + The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club + The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club,
the The Jonathan Club + The California Club + The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club, The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club.
That is the restrictions from under.
It's now illegal and punitive damages.
Big time.
And it's my privilege to play the lead role in that
and counsel member Joy Picus has led the fight.
You fight these battles wherever you can.
I took it seriously and the argument is for why the controller
would be involved.
You can't kid me.
Major decisions at the big time level are made by,
with people who get equated informally and make the deal
and other people do the paperwork.
They're done by people of a chance to get to know each other
and their families.
For example, the model in Embryo was my fraternity.
And that fight, there's a connection.
And the biracial counsels that got established in places like Savannah.
So, on other times when you have to push, I'm an affable man.
I can also be pretty tough.
And we pushed it hard.
And a lot of some of my friends who were in this lift didn't like it.
And my friends, others are now grateful because
the involvement of successful business women,
Latino blacks, Asian Americans, people who are Jewish,
other backgrounds, helps sustain these clubs
and some tough economic times here in Los Angeles.
And in addition to that, I became involved in the anti-aparitate fight
as controller.
And one thing I did was played a role.
Zev Yaroslavsky played a huge role in this councilman,
Robert C. Farrell, Mayor Bradford, which we got...
Dispos for a second.
Okay, Doc.
Okay, we're rolling.
Right, The Jonathan Club + The The Jonathan Club + The California Club + The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club + The Jonathan Club + The California Club + Hillcrest Country Club.
And another battle we got involved with.
There are plenty of other things you do when the controller's office
besides these fights.
But when it's important to do it, I won in 1985.
And as I mentioned, Sir, four terms.
Well, in that first term, we also were engaged in the battle
to turn out to be successful, by the way,
to get the City of Los Angeles to divest from any companies
who were doing business in South Africa.
I had been told reliably by a number of people
that some of the companies either lied or choose not to know
if they had ties there.
And so standing on the shoulders of the Solar Rights experience
is nothing like an affidavit.
And so I think my contribution was...
And then I want to give credit to the councils of Zev Yaroslavsky,
chairman of the Finance Committee, Robert C. Farrell,
who've been a freedom writer,
helped lead the way Tom Bradley and others.
But I think sworn affidavit helped,
that's a no kidding proposition.
He was...
He was in Los Angeles, but not on the council.
He had been elected to the state legislature.
And he had been elected in the 70s.
That was in the state of San Francisco.
Oh, sure. He was around.
Oh, yeah, we had.
And then we got involved in some redlining-disclosure ordinance
where you have your chance to get involved in those things.
This one banks merge as a point where in terms of disclosure,
you can learn a lot about their activities.
And so on, we got very much involved in those.
And these struggles go on as something we discussed just as we began
our interview this weekend, Rebecca and I.
Tonight doesn't matter if I fly to Sacramento
to the state Democratic Party meeting
where one of the things we'll be bringing up.
And hopefully the resolutions committee will support us in doing this
is a resolution from the California Democratic Party
which calls on the United States Supreme Court not to reverse
the 1965 Voting Rights Act, which I regard as an absolutely crucial
part of the two great civil rights acts,
and particularly the part having to do with federal pre-flair.
It's my own view is we need more time
under the Office of that Act to guarantee the rights of all Americans
to be able to vote in those particular states.
So these battles in various ways that go on.
Yeah, that's exactly what I was just going to say.
So here we are documenting civil rights movement
and you're still, you know, we're looking at still fighting this.
Fighting that fight and also one of the things that happened
is that that battle, not surprised about it,
it just flowed very naturally.
And I think I'm speaking of nothing particularly unique
or wide consensus on this.
We could see it at the time and that it would open up other rights
and be there rights of issues of gender equity,
rights for gay, lesbian, transgender Americans.
In fact, we were careful to put it on the floor of the council,
my support, that on the desecrigation of the large so-called private
clubs and Los Angeles would include people
regardless of sexual orientation, as well as gender issues
and race and so on.
So anyway, the battle, the struggles go on.
Well, let me just thank you very much.
Thank you for being part of this project and for your work.
Well, thank you.
Thank you for all you're doing.
I'm looking forward to reading your book on Western Mass.
What happened?
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.